Speaker 1: Federal judges in two states have
issued contradictory decisions that could
significantly impact access to a drug that
is used in nearly all medication abortions
here in the United States. U.S. District Judge
Matthew Cosmetic in Texas ruled that the Food
and Drug Administration, the FDA, improperly
approves the abortion pill. Martha Preston,
over 20 years ago. And he issued a nationwide
injunction pausing the FDA's approval of the drug,
which is set to take effect in seven days from the
time of the ruling. This marks the first time in
history that a court has claimed the authority
to singlehandedly pull a drug from the market.
It's legally dubious that a judge has this sort of
wide ranging power. Within hours of that decision,
U.S. District Judge Thomas Price issued a ruling
in a separate case in Washington state that blocks
the FDA from, quote, altering the status quo
and rights as it relates to the availability
of mifepristone. The problem, of course, is that
the FDA cannot conceivably comply with both of
these contradictory orders at once. And because
cosmetics order is broader covering all 50 states,
it guarantees that if a person will be suspended
in much of the country, at least temporarily.
Only the Supreme Court can resolve this
looming crisis. It has very little time to
do so. The window is closing and knowing
how right wing this Supreme Court is,
particularly on the abortion issue, this could
spell disaster. President Biden said about this,
quote, If this ruling were to stands, then there
will be virtually no prescription approved by
the FDA that would be safe from these kinds of
political ideological attacks. It is the next
step towards the national ban on abortion that
Republican elected officials have vowed to make
law in America. The Justice Department appealed to
the U.S. Court of Appeals for the fifth District,
which has a reputation for being conservative,
unfortunately. Mifepristone was approved by
the FDA back in 2000 for use in combination
with a second drug called misoprostol. More
than half of all abortions in United
States are done using a medication,
and the two drug combination has been used in
90% of them since 2020. So as David likes to say,
this is shocking but not surprising. We knew that
when the conservative Supreme Court overturned Roe
versus Wade last year, that Republicans were
not going to be content with just that alone,
because, you know, the overturning of Roe versus
Wade still allows for abortion to take place
in the United States. It basically just kicks
the issue back to the states. But to be clear,
the use of mifepristone cannot be compared to
the medical procedure known as abortion at all. I
mean, these are two different things. I think both
should be legal, but the circumstances surrounding
both of these issues are very different. The
main difference, of course, is the timing,
right? Because a regular abortion procedure will
typically be performed after a couple of months of
pregnancy, you know, maybe 6 to 12 weeks into the
pregnancy, whereas an abortion pill can be taken
up to about 11 weeks after the first day of the
last menstrual period. The procedure, of course,
is very different, with one requiring a medical
professional to surgically removed the fetus
from the uterus, while the other is as simple
as taking a pill. I understand that. You know,
there's an ethical conundrum when you're talking
about ending the pregnancy, when the fetus is at
the end of the second trimester or the beginning
of the third trimester or what have you. But this
is not what this is. This is effectively a clump
of cells that we're talking about just several
weeks into a pregnancy. And effectively, what
you're doing by banning these abortion pills, by
trying to ban them, is delaying when a woman can
likely get the procedure done. And this will give
the fetus more time to develop, not to mention all
at cost. It it'll add stress to the woman who's
going through their predicaments. But Republicans,
they don't care about that sort of stuff. They
see pregnancy as a punishment for having sex
and they're not interested in real solutions.
They're not interested in abortion pills or day
after pills. They're not interested in other
types of contraception. They're not interested in
sexual education. They want to maximize suffering
on this issue, increase unwanted pregnancies, keep
people in this cycle of poverty. Since, of course,
parenthood is so incredibly expensive and often
people who are considering abortions are doing
so because they can't afford to have a child or
another child. Obviously, Republicans aren't in
support of social programs too. That would help
the babies once they're actually born. So Judge
Matthew Kaczmarek is digging up this matter from
20 years ago that's so incredibly legally dubious
so that he can play politics, too, in. Course, his
strict father morality view. And it's sickening to
see how much we've regressed in the year 2023.
Good. On District Judge Tommaso Rice issuing
a ruling in a separate case here and good on the
Biden administration for trying to challenge this.